At this point, you have built a fairly
complete back end authentication,
database handler, services,
repositories, caching, background jobs,
and in the last two videos also object
storage. And through all of it, every
single thing our back end has ever done
has followed exactly one shape, which is
the browser asks a question and the
server answers it. Now, let's talk about
another requirement. Since we are
building from a product angle and it's a
fairly ordinary one. We have a task
management application. Let's say you
build that and two people are looking at
the same board and one of them drags a
task from to-do to in progress and the
other person sitting somewhere else in
the world should see the task move live.
not on the page refresh, not on
navigation but live. And the moment you
start thinking about how to implement
this feature, I mean without having the
knowledge of how to implement this the
right way, all the tools that are
available to us, all the technologies,
but if you just think about it without
any prior knowledge, then one limitation
that you'll quickly realize is this one.
So far whatever we have been doing it's
always have been the case that the
client initiates the conversation. The
client starts the communication. The
server cannot start the communication.
It has no mechanism to speak first. It
can only reply to something the browser
has already asked for or it can hold a
communication for a long time but the
starting itself it cannot do and I said
this in video five in the H video that
every time the client initiates and the
server responds that is the model. So at
any point if the server has some news
some information which the browser has
not explicitly asked for then there is
no way to let the information travel
from server to our browser or our
client. So as usual let's do the same
exercise. What is the most intuitive way
to go about the solution? So if the
server cannot tell us when something has
changed or some new information then the
only way to implement that is through
the client and how which is constantly
asking for some information in a loop.
So every 3 seconds or so the browser the
client asks the server has anything
changed on this particular module or
let's say in this case the example was
of this board this task management
board. So every 3 seconds the browser
will ask the server has something
changed in this board this particular
board that I'm looking at with the ID
412 or something in the last 3 seconds
and depending on the data volume most of
the time the answer will be no
occasionally in this case when the user
has actually moved a task from one board
to another then the answer will be yes
something has changed then the server
will send either the particular change
that has happened or it will just say
that okay some change has happened
please refetch the whole board data and
rerender the whole screen. Here we have
a polling demo where we have two
browsers side by side and both of them
are doing the polling operation that I
mentioned. they are pulling every 3
seconds and as you can see from these
two counters the request counter and the
change counter which most of the time
stays same except when let's say AAS
browser it moved one task and the moment
it does in the next counter of Leo's
browser the unchanged counter does not
increase it stays the same because some
change happened so that request did not
go to waste But other times every 3
seconds the poll that is happening most
of the times the request counter and the
unchanged counter both go up which means
that you are wasting most of your
requests where no change has happened.
And this whole polling setup works
pinging your server every 3 seconds to
ask for information. the solution works
and if you have some kind of internal
tooling with a few users then pulling
every few seconds makes sense and is a
perfectly reasonable decision for that
architecture. But here since we are
talking about a userfacing product front
and we want to do the right solution
with scales that is why we are not going
to stop here. we will keep pushing the
boundary of what is going to break at
what level and what is the right thing
to do. So the first problem that you see
here that you can feel is the delay. If
you poll every 3 seconds, then on
average a change, whatever change
happened, whether a task moved from one
board to another or a task got updated
or deleted, something happened, then
that change waits at least 1 and a half
seconds on average before the other user
or any other user sees it live on their
screen. Pure arithmetic. So the average
delay is always going to be half of your
interval, whatever interval that you're
choosing. In this case it is 3 seconds.
So the average delay will be around 1.5
seconds. So what is the solution to
that? Pull faster. Do not keep a delay
which is visible to the user. Make it 1
second. So let's see what is going to
break when we make the polling interval
to 1 second. Let's say your product is
doing reasonably well in the market and
you have around 10,000 people with the
board open at one point. So 10,000
browsers open at once. Each one is
asking or each one is sending a request
to your server every 3 seconds. That is
3,33
requests every second reaching your back
end forever. And each one of those
requests they are proper HTTP request
which means they go through your load
balancer then through your
authentication middleware. So in your
authentication middleware you are also
validating the token and then it goes
through your logging middleware. So
you're also writing a log line to
somewhere. Then it goes to into a
service layer which does queries to the
database and then in the end through
serialization comes back as a output as
a JSON which means 3,000 database
queries per second and pretty much all
of them return the same answer which is
nothing has changed every time at least
most of the time which means that if you
drop the interval to reduce the
userfacing delay to make the whole
interface is snappier. That in turn
makes that 10,000 requests per second.
Which means you made the whole user
experience three times better. But the
cost, the compute or whatever resource
that you are paying for it, it is now
your bill that you're going to pay to
your cloud infrastructure at the end of
the month. That is now three times more
or three times worse. Now the cost of
polling scales with the number of users.
It does not scale with the number of
events. What does that mean? Let's say
there is a board where nothing happens
all day. No event is happening on that
board. But still the the amount of
resource that board is costing you,
where nothing is happening, no event is
happening, no change is happening. It is
the same as a board where some event
some change is happening every second
which means that you're not actually
paying with your resources for the
actual change. You are paying for the
whole communication for the requests
itself which obviously feels wrong
because the the thing that is bringing
us value is the events itself the
changes itself not the requests itself.
They are just a medium and a very wrong
medium in this case. Also, if your users
are on a mobile phone, then every single
poll that happens through a phone, it
wakes something called as the radio,
which is one of the most expensive thing
a phone does. So because of this your
polling loop your users battery and
their data is both draining at a faster
pace than usual for no changes at all on
the board that they are looking at. So
far we have realized what is the right
solution for this shift which is the
server should speak first which will
eliminate all these problems that we are
seeing here. And the second one is we
should only pay with our resources for
the actual changes for the actual events
and not per the user the number of
browsers or the number of requests.
Those are just our mediums. They are not
what is bringing us value. So that is
why the rest of this video is going to
be about that. How to achieve that
result, what it looks like on the
network level itself, how much does it
cost on resources and any other topics
around. The first idea people had was
very simple which is if the server can
only answer a question which was what
our primary limitation with the HTTP
protocol was which is a client has to
initiate the communication and server
can only reply back. So since that is
our constraint then the solution people
came up to solve this whole real-time
thing is ask a question and let the
server take its time before answering.
That's the whole shape of the very
simple initial solution and in technical
term we call it as long polling where
what happens the browser sends a request
and the server does not reply
immediately. It holds that request open
the request open by not sending a
response back immediately sometimes for
a minute just waiting. The moment
something happens, some kind of change
happens, it writes the response for that
change with some information and sends
the response back and that request
closes. The browser gets that
immediately and then it starts another
request, another cycle of long polling.
And if you see it is actually written
down in RFC 6202
along with all the things that is wrong
with the solution. But to summarize the
the the reason this solution is wrong is
the gap that happens there after the
server answers the browser has to
process the whole response then open a
fresh request to the server and during
that whole window the server has no
connection to you and according to this
RFC the average latency is about one
network transit but if you look at the
worst case scenario it is more than
three because of that gap thing. So the
long polling solution it works and for a
lot of years people used it to solve the
real-time problem but eventually we had
to move on from it to the next idea and
what that next idea is this is a little
cleverer than the previous one which is
this whole thing happens we are doing
this long polling but what if the
response just never ends right clients
starts a request the browser starts a
request
and waits. That's it. Whenever something
happens, the server keeps sending it,
but it does not close that request. It
just holds that request open and keeps
sending data through that medium. That
is exactly what we call as server send
events. The browser makes a very normal
ordinary looking HTTP get request. The
server replies with the status 200 with
an extra header of content type which
has text /event dashream. Then it simply
just does not close that connection that
the client has opened. Every time it
wants to send some information, it just
writes a little bit of text in the same
connection, sends it back to the client,
and that connection is kept open
forever. And by forever we mean as long
as the browser is still there, the tab
is still there. The moment the tab
closes or the browser closes or some
network connection happens from the
client side, then of course the request
will be closed. And depending on the
retry mechanism or reload mechanism on
the client side, the request will be
opened again. But if the client is open,
if the client is working, if our
platform is open on the browser side,
then there will always be a connection
to the server for this whole
communication thing. That is the whole
idea. And the interesting part is it is
not a different protocol. It is still on
top of HTTP. It still uses the HTTP
header and the response body for all
kinds of communication. And here as you
can see we are starting a s request
since we are using call to act as a
client and communicating with this
server that is running on our local and
we are starting an http request and we
are predeclaring that uh we are
accepting the text event stream data
then the moment we start with the / ai/
event where whatever endpoint the server
is listening to start this connection
then we start getting all these events.
that you can see each event here has an
ID has the event name itself which is
like task move task deleted task created
etc and then the data itself so that the
client the front end can take that data
and directly render it on the screen by
inserting a new card or something and
the reason we are adding this ID here so
that if at some point the connection got
closed or something or the tab was
refreshed or closed something happened
then the client can save this last ID
and it can send it back to the server
that okay this is the ID of the last
event that I received so send me all the
events since then instantly so that it
can render all the changes on the screen
there won't be any delay while it tries
to catch up to the server there is also
one more field called retry and that is
used by the server so that it can tell
the browser how long to wait before
doing the whole reconnection thing and
this is the whole specification of the
format of server send events just four
fields that we are seeing here now
because the server send events this
whole protocol is in the edge standard
the browser itself implements the
reconnection for you if the connection
drops the browser waits and reconnects
on its own you don't really have to
write an extra code for that and when it
reconnects it sends a header called last
event ID that I just mentioned which
carries the ID of the last event it
received. The browser itself your code
does not have to do that. Now people who
are familiar with all the options that
are available for realtime systems which
is the most famous one that is
websockets because of that some people
think that server send events is like an
inferior version or some kind of toy
implementation in front of the actual
architecture which is websockets which
is not true. If you look at Uber's push
platform which tells a driver about a
trip that itself was built on server
sent events. Similarly, if you look at
LinkedIn's instant messaging feature
which also has these typing indicators
and read receipts, they also used server
sent events. And the reason is since it
is all they did not have to think about
compatibility between different
different devices and environments. It
just worked everywhere. And in this era
of agentic coding, all of us pretty much
use different different kinds of CLI
tools for interacting with our agents.
And every single large language model,
LLM model that we use, its API streams
all its tokens to your client either to
your CLI, to your browser, whatever
using server sent events. So when you're
watching that uh text being streamed one
token at a time, one word at a time,
that is exactly that data field that we
just saw in the demo that is being
rendered. So service and events is not a
inferior implementation. It has its
uses. just have to see where exactly
server send events fits in your
architecture and where do you need
something more powerful which we'll
cover soon. So server send events gives
us the whole server speaking first
capability over plain HTTP and on top of
that we also have browsers uh natively
supporting reconnection and resuming any
connection related errors. So what is
the limitation here? Why are we still
trying to look for a better solution?
Which is the name itself? If you look at
the name server send events, what that
means is it is one direction only. The
server can talk all day like constantly.
It can keep sending all the information
it wants to browser to our client. But
if the browser wants to communicate
something to the server using the same
connection or using the same real-time
connection, it cannot. For example, in a
task management app, if the user drags a
task and it wants to let the server know
about this information, that is going to
be a separate post request that cannot
share the same connection. And for a lot
of features, for a lot of products, that
is a completely fine architecture. But
in this case, since we are trying to
learn about all the options and what is
the best option for our this feature,
which is the live board feature, we want
both directions on one connection. And
that is why let's look at the technology
that offers us that exact feature, which
is two-way communication on the same
connection. So here we are using a tool
called websocket to experiment with our
whole websocket architecture using a
server which is running on the port 7821
and it is exposing the whole websocket
connection feature on the /echo endpoint
and using this tool we are trying to
initiate a connection to the same
endpoint. The moment we start, we see a
couple of info logs here which says a
few things and then it says connected to
this particular server at port 7821
through TCP. Right? Then if you focus on
the line which says connected to
websocket and the response headers that
we received is upgrade websocket
connection upgrade and there is a header
called sec websocket accept. We'll come
back to what that is. Once that is done,
this whole thing is called the websocket
handshake. Once this is established, now
we can start communicating with the
server. Here we are seeing that a okay a
task moved on board 412 and the server
instantly replies what we sent to the
server and then in the next line the
server also sends some information back
which we are rendering here. Then we
send some information back and so on and
so forth. the two-way connection works
in the whole websocket architecture. So
the thing to focus here some of the
interesting things is websocket
connection itself it does not start as a
websocket. It starts as a normal HTTP
get request and that is pretty powerful
because it travels through everything
that already understands HTTP which
means every single device that we can
imagine pretty much all of them speak
HTTP by default. So the browser sends a
get request with a header saying upgrade
websocket and a header called sec
websocket key with a 16 random bytes
with base 64 encoded. Then the server
takes that key. It adds a fixed string
to the end of that. Takes the S1 hash of
the whole result. Then it B 64 encodes
that and sends it back in a header
called SEC websocket accept along with
the whole status code 101 which means
switching protocols from HTTP to
websocket and the fixed string that I
mentioned that is a constant and it is
written in the specification and it
sounds like it is for security but it is
not because anyone can compute it. Whole
job of this key is to prove that the
thing that is answering it understood
that you asked for a websocket
and it is not just a cache that is
replaying an old 200 response. So once
that exchange is done the part is over
the connection still stays open but it
is not HTTP anymore. Everything changes.
No headers, no methods, no status codes.
It is now a completely new birectional
stream of data and both sides can write
whenever they want. And this birectional
stream of data it is also called
birectional stream of frames. What is a
frame? The RFC says it is a bit diagram
where the first bit is FIN or FIN which
says that it is the last piece of a
message. Then comes three reserved bits.
After that four bits of op code which
says what kind of frame it is. One means
text, two means binary, 8 means close
and nine means ping, 10 means pong and
zero means this is just a continuation
of the previous message. Then one bit
called mask. After that seven bits of
payload length, which is a very
efficient design. If your payload is
under 126 bytes, the length is just that
number and the whole header just cost
you two bytes. If it is bigger, you
write 126 there and the real length in
two more bytes. But if it is like huge,
you write 127 followed by 8 bytes. So a
small message just has a two byte
header. Compared to our earlier long
polling approach where every polling
request had hundreds of bytes of
headers, we can already see the kind of
resource saving that is happening here.
Now let's talk about that masked bit.
Every single frame the browser sends to
the server is what we call as masked.
And what that masked means is each bite
of the payload is x odd with one bite of
a four byte key. And it cycles through
the key as you go. And this key is sent
in every single frame four bytes in
front of the payload. And it is sent in
clear text. It is not an encryption.
Anyone reading the whole network can
read it with just one line of code. So
why does it exist in the first place?
The reason is while the protocol was
being written, someone ran an experiment
against real caching proxies that were
deployed over the internet and then
poisoned them. What that means is the
whole attack looks something like a a
malicious page would open a connection
to a server that the attacker controls
then does something that looks like an
HTTP upgrade and then sends bytes in
that connection which are carefully
written to look like a fresh get request
for some kind of popular file. let's say
some kind of tracking script like Google
Analytics or something like that which
thousands of sites load then a proxy is
in the middle which does not really
understand this whole protocol. It sees
that is just a request and a response
and it caches that response and the
moment it does that everyone behind that
proxy gets the attacker's file when they
ask for the real one. That's the whole
framing of this attack. And to counter
that, what they came up was this
masking. So if the browser exors
everything with a fresh random key which
the pages JavaScript cannot predict,
then the attacker cannot choose the
bytes that appear on the network. They
can choose what they send, but they
cannot choose what it looks like after
the masking. And because of that they
cannot do the fake HTTP request in the
stream. And this is why the key should
be and must be random. And as per the
specification it says the FG for each
frame. So masking in this case is not
there to protect your data but it is to
protect the whole arrangement between
you and your user the whole
communication. Now let's talk about two
more frame types because they are
important. Op code 9 which we said is
for ping and op code 10 which is for
pong. Any of the sides either client or
the server they can send a ping and the
other one must send a pong back which
means just a response back. That is what
we call as a heartbeat. And we need this
whole thing. Why? Because of TCP. If a
connection dies or gets interrupted
because either the user walked into a
lift or their phone switched from Wi-Fi
to mobile data. If something like that
happens, then you do not really get
anything. They do not send you anything.
There is no error. There is no close,
nothing like that. and your server is
just there holding a socket and it it
believes that the client is still there
and it will keep holding on to it for a
very long time because from the server's
point of view from the sockets's point
of view an idle connection and a dead
connection looks exactly the same
because nothing is happening there. So
the only way to tell them apart is to
send something and see if something
comes back to see if the other side is
still there or not. And that is exactly
why we have this ping and pong setup. In
actual websocket based setups, we have
these constraint where if some side
sends a ping and the other side does not
send a pong within 30 seconds, the
connection is considered as dead and the
other side can close it and it can free
whatever resource it was holding. Right?
So now we have persistent connections.
Both directions can talk. Now, now the
question is how many of these
connections a particular machine can
hold. So this is a plain uh Linux
machine. It has 16 cores of CPU and 61
GB of free memory. And this is a
websocket server written with a few
lines of go which does nothing apart
from accept connections and hold on to
them. There is no application logic
because what we want to measure is how
many connection we can hold. So let's
check what are our limits exactly. If
you know about file descriptors in Unix
machines like Linux, Mac etc. Everything
is a file which means a socket a network
socket itself is a file and to interact
with that you have a file descriptor. So
every connection is a file as far as the
kernel is concerned. There is some
abstractions on top of it. So the number
of connections you can hold is directly
related to the number of files you can
have open in your operating system. So
if we run this command called ulimit- n
it says that 1,024
that's how many files you can keep open.
I'm starting this server which has this
limit configured and then we'll open
2,00 connections at it and we will see
where does it exactly stop and it stops
at 1,17
which is exactly right because we have
things like a bunch of standard input
standard output standard error the
listening socket itself and the eole
instance that the runtime is using to
watch all of
And there are like a seven file
descriptors of overhead. And after all
that we have 1,7 connections. Now let's
look at what the client saw. It did not
get connection refused. No kind of error
at all. It just got a timeout and it was
just waiting there for a handshake for a
reconnection. But if you look at the
server, it shows the exact reason which
is too many files open and it keeps
showing that reason with some kind of
exponential backoff. So the server is
not down, it is up and it is very much
healthy. It is still answering any kind
of health check APIs we have configured
but it is refusing to accept any new
connections. We said that the limit is
1,024.
Now let's see something else. It is the
same shell and it is the same Linux
machine that we saw earlier. And if we
ask the go program what is the file
descriptor limit is then it says
1,4,575.
And if we ask Python in the same shell,
it says,24.
Why? because the Go runtime itself
raises its own limit when it is starting
up. Here if you open the standard
library of Go here the comment explains
the same thing that some systems set an
artificially low soft limit for
compatibility with code that uses select
which has a hard-coded maximum file
descriptor because of the size of FD set
but Go does not use select. So the go
team decided that the runtime should
just raise the limit for itself and let
the old software as it is. And if you
look at this line, it sets the new limit
to the maximum minus one intentionally
so that it can detect somebody else
changing the limit later. That is why
the number we saw was 1,48,575
not 576.
So the famous quote that we hear which
is you will hit a thousand file
descriptors problem that exists but it
is language dependent. If you are
writing node or python or java then you
will face that issue but if you are
writing go then you have much more
flexibility here. Now that we have
removed that limitation, let's say we
are using go and we have no limitation
on the file description. So now we have
1 million descriptors. Let's see from
this point how far we can go. If you try
again, it stops at 28,190.
Then it is dead. But this time with a
completely different error which is
cannot assign requested address. So to
investigate this, let's ask the kernel
itself which port numbers it is allowed
to use when it makes an outgoing
connection. And it says 32,768
up to 60,999.
If you subtract and add one that is
28,232
available ports. So we got 28,190
and we have to subtract 42 because this
is a shared machine and 42 of those
ports are already in use by some other
services. But the point is that the
whole limitation here is something that
you can calculate beforehand before you
face this error. And this time we did
not run out of memory and we did not run
out of file descriptors but we ran out
of port numbers where on the server not
on the client. A lot of people believe
that a server can only hold 65,000
connections because there are only
65,000 ports. That is not true because a
T connection is not identified by a
port. It is identified by four things.
The source address, the source port, the
destination address and the destination
port. And every connection just has to
be unique across all four. Our server
has one address and one port. And that
never changes. So every connection to it
must be different in the other two
places. Our client also had one address
which means that there is exactly one
thing which needs to be different across
every connection which is our own source
port which was we just checked 28,000 of
them and that is the limit which belongs
to the client which also means that the
fix for this is not getting a bigger
server. So what we can try here, let's
give the client three addresses to dial
out from instead of one. And we will ask
for 25,000 on each one. So 75,000 total
connections. And we have zero failures.
The server is holding 75,000
and 9 file descriptors, which is our
75,000 sockets and the same as before.
And this is exactly why when you are
trying to do load testing in your
production, you'll need different
machines and several of them to get to
the number to get to the load that you
can handle. So now that we can actually
generate the load, we have seen how what
is the limitation now which is the
memory. Our server was at around 7 and
half MB of memory doing nothing with
75,000 connections that are currently
open. It was at 722
MB. If you subtract and divide, each
connection costs about 9,750
bytes. And that is our servers processes
heap, its own heap per connection. It is
not the total cost to the machine
because the kernel has its own
structures for every socket and that
does not appear in the processes
resident memory. And I tried to measure
it three times because that's how you
can reach at a definite number. It came
out as first 9,51
9,881
bytes. So if you multiply out 1 million
connections is going to be a bit under
10 GB of heap before the kernel takes
its own share. So on a 61 GB of box that
is pretty much easily achievable. So all
in all what we learn from this whole
thing is a million idle connections is
pretty much boils down to your RAM your
memory and also most of that 9 kilobytes
that we saw is not the socket. It is
going to be the go routine that we
spawned to watch it monitor it and the
buffers we gave it. And that is why
people trying very large numbers. They
don't use go routines per connection.
Instead, they watch every socket from
one place using e- pole. Now we learned
that one machine can hold a lot of
connection depending on how much the RAM
is. But the issue is you will not have
one machine in your production. You will
have multiple of them because of the
whole autoscaling and all architecture.
And when there are multiple machines and
when you also consider deployments where
a container state dies and a new
container comes up in all these
scenarios you also have to think about
dropping every single one of your users
connection and picking them up again and
what happens when a machine dies and a
container dies suddenly all these
scenarios. So to understand that this is
the same board with two instances of our
server behind a load balancer. Now
browser A connects and the load balancer
sends it to instance one. Next browser B
connects and that gets sent to instance
two. Both are healthy. Both have a live
web soocket. Now I move a task in
browser A and nothing happens in browser
B. Why? Because if you think about it,
where does that connection live?
Instance one has a socket in its memory,
a go routine and a note somewhere that
this particular socket is involved with
board 412. Now instance 2 has never
heard about browser A and it cannot
because there are two separate process
and probably in two different countries.
We spent pretty much our whole playlist
making our backend stateless so that any
instance can serve any request. But now
in this video we're saying that a
persistent connection is a state and it
lives in one specific process memory and
it cannot be moved and it cannot be
shared. So the moment you accept a web
soocket that instance is the only
instance in the world that can talk to
the user. So what do we do now? This is
a very big contradiction to what we have
been building so far. Some people
suggest this solution called as sticky
session. What a sticky session is a
sticky session tells the load balancer
to keep sending the client the same
client back to the same instance and it
should do the same behavior for
reconnection. Also with sticky sessions,
browser A keeps connecting to instance
one, but that does not really solve the
problem which is browser B is still on
instance 2 and it still does not have
any idea about browser A. So sticky
sessions is not the right solution here.
It is a completely different problem
that trying to solve. Our problem here
is two clients at the same time. the
instances themselves have to talk to
each other. So the solution that most of
us arrive at is going to be pubsub or
publish and subscribe which is when
something happens on board 412 the
instance that receives it instead of
trying to deliver it what it does is it
publishes to a topic and something some
tool in the middle radius or nats or
kafka any of these popsup tools
They hand that event to every subscribed
instance for that topic and each one of
them then looks at their own connections
and they find the one watching for that
board and they write the frame. So the
instance that receives the change and
the instance that delivers now they can
be on different machines. That is the
whole architecture of making the
instances talk for realtime events. We
again have two browsers again have two
instances but there is one difference
where here this user moves a task. AA
moves a task but this time Leo sees it
instantly because of the whole event
publish and subscribe architecture.
There is a one note here which is if
you're using radius so its whole popsup
model the publish and subscribe model is
what we call as fire and forget. So
because of that if an instance is not
connected at the exact moment that you
publish that message is gone forever.
There is no way to cue it. There is no
way to delay it or retry anything just
gone. So think about this scenario where
uh a deployment happens and an instance
goes down the container goes down and
it's replacement container goes up and
in the seconds that in in the seconds
between them between all this happens
the one instance going down and another
coming up every message that is
published for the users that the
particular instance was serving those
messages are gone completely. So the
other boards that were depending on the
updates for those events the only time
they see those events is when they do a
refresh again. So this is a
architectural decision which is if you
are using radius pubsub for this you
have to be aware of the limitation that
radius offers you a model of delivering
at most once. So if you need the
alternative model which is at least once
then you need something else which
stores your messages and also sends
acknowledgements for them which means
something like ready streams or Kafka or
Q something like that instead of radius
popsup which brings us to the question
which is what happens to a message that
was published when a user was not
connected because that is a very common
scenario connections might drop, a phone
changes its network from Wi-Fi to mobile
data, or maybe the laptop's lid is
closed by someone, or the load balancer
hits its idle timeout. So in a real
production grade realtime system, you
have to take into account all of these
things and you have to think about what
is your catching up strategy. Not just
delivering strategy but catching up in
case some kind of connection error
happens, connection failure happens. And
the shape of the solution is something
that we have already seen in the server
send events which is name all your
messages or ID all your messages and
make the client who is communicating
with you tell you the last ID or the
last number it actually received and
send everything after that. In case of
any kind of connection error, a platform
like Uber, they do exactly this. A
client connects and it says I am at
sequence zero and then the service
starts sending the messages with
increasing sequence numbers. If at any
point the connection breaks, the client
reconnects and says I was able to get up
to sequence number two. So the server
takes that and then it starts from three
because that's where the client was
errored out. This is exactly what we saw
with the server send events using the
header last event ID. Now the last thing
that I want to cover is what we call as
fan out. We just saw above that to solve
the problem of multiple instances you do
the whole publish and subscribe model.
But if we consider that if 30,000 people
are watching the same board then one
person moving one task means that your
server has to perform 30,000 rightes.
The actual work that your server has to
perform is the number of events
multiplied by the number of subscribers.
Discord had wrote about this once
because they had scenarios where they
had communities with 30,000 people
online at once and they measured that
publishing a single event to one of
those took somewhere between 900
milliseconds to up to 2.1 seconds for
one message for a platform like Discord.
core architecture is about messaging.
And the solution they found for this
problem was instead of doing the fan out
in one place, spread out, spread the
whole work across different machines who
actually owns the recipients. Let's also
pay attention to the mechanism of
reconnect. So think about an instance
which is holding 50,000 connections and
if that instant dies all the connections
that it is holding all the clients they
all start reconnecting at the same
moment and the moment they connect all
of them want their initial state which
boards which tasks who is online which
means 50,000 expensive requests in 1
second and this is the scenario that was
written by Slack and the Fix for this
was to make the connecting part cheap by
keeping a cache at the edge of the
network which holds the information of
what a client needs to start so that
whenever a reconnection load happens, a
reconnection storm happens, it does not
reach the origin. It does not reach the
core. Okay. Now to summarize everything,
we started with a server that could only
reply to questions to a connection which
was started from the browser. And to
beat that, we started with polling which
worked. But the price it cost was the
number of people watching instead of the
number of things happening, number of
changes happening or events happening.
Then the alternative that we considered
was long polling which holds a request
open which again had some of these
problems because of the gap between the
client receiving the response processing
it and starting another request. It lost
some changes. So to counter that we came
up with a different variation of the
long polling which is server send
events. So instead of closing the
request after sending the response back,
the server keeps the connection open.
But the limitation then we faced was the
client the browser itself could not send
any messages back to the server and to
counter that we came up with websockets
which starts as a h request then it
upgrades to a websocket protocol with
things like uh bite headers and masking
which protects proxies. we try to
measure on a machine. The first
limitation that we faced was the file
descriptors which is because in Unix
everything is a file because of that the
socket is also a file and we saw that
different programming languages have
different limits and if you are using go
then you can go up to 1 million. Then
the next limitation that we faced was a
client's port range not servers
limitation the client's limitation and
to counter that we configured so that
the client dials out from different
different ports instead of a single port
and in the end the limitation or the the
ceiling that we faced was the memory
which was around 9.6 six kilobytes of
heap per connection. And then we saw the
problem of persistent connection
handling scenarios where our server is
divided into multiple instances for
different reasons like scaling and then
containers restarting and all these
things. And to counter that the
architecture that we came up with is
popsup publish and subscribe. That's
pretty much a brief about realtime
systems and how clients and servers
handle it using different different
strategies. Now there is also a lot of
things that we did not cover things like
presence system to see which users are
currently online in our platform and
also collaborative editing where two
people can change the same thing at the
same time and someone has to win. If you
have used platforms like notion or
Google docs, they show live cursors of
two people editing the same text at the
same time. All of those can push the
limits and the capabilities of realtime
systems to a 10 hours of lecture because
each one of them open a door into
multiple technologies. Like if you are
talking about the collaborative editing
space then you have to understand
algorithms like CRDT how they work over
the wire and all those stuff. But
everything that we talked about in this
video is the foundation on top of which
we can keep adding more and more
capabilities.